thanks dad man I could play unknown 2058
okay we'll play this guy I'm black again
well two blacks in the row he's online
never play them before he's from Peru
Wow
Peru is I think doing pretty well in the
Olympian I think they're one of their
top players is doing incredibly well
Jorge Corey there's like a twenty nine
hundred plus performance rating okay I'm
gonna play a French I don't know too
many lines after Knight c3 let's take
and I'll play the Fort Knox variation
with Bishop d7 I was showing this to a
student the other day as kind of an easy
opening to learn because it's just a
matter of developing normally and then
trying to outplay the opponent later in
the middle game and there's some there
was some interesting nuance which I'm
gonna try and remember starting with
Bishop c6 and then I think first playing
Knight d7 to prepare Knight f6
and the lines can branch out pretty
quickly but I remember this is like the
main position where things can start
branching out depending what light does
me can I take f6 as a move and Knight g3
is a move
maybe Bishop g5 s a move I shouldn't
just say all the all the moves for my
opponents but if he's watching I guess
he still has to make a decision so you
know let's play Queen take f6 Wow he
plays c3 right away let us say there is
a chop in that position
maybe he maybe he's still in prep
maybe not he's taken some time let's
play Bishop g6 there's still a chop
which exists
but all ahem play a move first
I will say this is one of the main
positions I was looking at like the
other day like this exact position and
then the idea of like attacking on the
Kings side with the two bishops combined
with the Queen and there might even be
some cases where I could Castle
queenside and there's also some cases
where I can just take on f3 have a more
positional game especially if we trade
Queens but I don't think there's any
rush to take on that three right away
that's interesting question also what
does white do here like he's developed I
mean he should probably develop this
bishop but in terms of long term plans I
don't see anything immediate for whites
because I'm controlling a lot of key
squares controlling ePHI for the time
being nine bishops are just nice I guess
if I commit to castling queenside that
would give him a very clear plan of like
attacking so I have to be careful when I
commit to I mean I could Castle
queenside I will also say because it's
clear my opponent sees us the trap was
if he played Bishop g5 that would be a
blunder due to Bishop take f3 and then
black would win material so it's clear
he's not gonna go for Bishop g5 rook e1
I think is very normal move I'm inclined
to play h3 here with idea of g5
and I'm still not sure which way I want
to castle
Ricky one doesn't appear to have a
threat let's play on page six patient
move probably could have played that
quicker somewhat tense position though
at some point I'll have to make some
commitments either have to commit to
like going for an attack with g5 or
commit to taking on f3 or commit to
castling queenside I don't always like
to make commitments so like I usually
like to stay flexible and then determine
what to play after my opponent makes a
commitment sometimes you just can't
overthink things
mmm so he may be discouraging me from
castling and this is an interesting
moment like this is kind of what I was
waiting for because now I might shift
like shift plans because now okay b5
like he could potentially play b5 Bishop
e5 c4 and then force a trade maybe you
know the bad thing I'm thinking about
taking right away
expecting Queen take we trade Queens and
that I can go for a 5 try and undermine
his his pawn but then he plays b5 I can
play a four typical move and c4 mmm I
can also take right away maybe the idea
that after everything gets traded I've
see 6 followed by some later a5
so a couple options I could also just
play g5 and that could well what does g5
accomplish because he still provokes me
to take on a3 so maybe that doesn't do
anything so I'll probably okay I'll
probably end up taking on a3 it's a
question of whether I want to let him
play b5 or just take immediately not
entirely sure
leaving towards taking immediately
tick-tick-tick c6 positional game or if
I play a five first a fib five probably
just helps whites okay let's trade
I like positions like if I had perhaps
one strengths in chess or one type of
position I enjoy playing and squamous
middle games with some imbalances in
here then balances are okay clearly pawn
structure and also fact White has a
bishop pair but maybe my knight can be
useful if it comes to d5 at some points
my opponent in the chat saying that we
played before not in chess but in drops
wonder if he's a strong drafts player
having played troughs in a while
I'm gonna have a slow type of game
unless he wants to like destroy me
immediately I mean he could go for F for
threatening out five but then I probably
played g6 hold everything together
and someday I might just want to like
exploit these pawns I play g5 and then
get a knifed at four or at Bishop to f4
envisioning like if I get a Knight to d5
pawn to g5 and play Bishop f4 okay
nevermind so my first impression was g6
I guess he could still play f5 but then
I take in Castle queenside let's play g6
because now his pawn is slightly stuck
on f4 and it's stuck on a square where
both my bishop and my knight can
potentially attack it so the plan is
Knight f6 Knight d5 and this line I
think is nice for me because I Castle
queenside and I'll control I'll start
attacking on the G file I got some
initiative
so b55 it was interesting he wants to
maybe at some point played d5 but if I
take so you play d5 immediately
and my king was a bit bit out of play
here bit misplaced so I have some idea
of taking if Bishop take I have a six it
should be okay and if I take in d5 I can
Castle queenside then he has a choice of
which pawn to take he'd probably take on
e6 first if he takes with rook
I have zucchini Knight c5 and they see
five would fork the rook and the bishop
and another line if see JP v d5 Castle
queenside we tray them and he takes on
b5 again I have 95 defending e6 and then
the F file would be half open so Rick f8
and I can start exploiting this pawn I
could just liquidate but let's go for
that
this is casual so there's no rating
points on the line as much as I would
like to break 2300 but yeah he has a
decision because g5 it's the difference
between d5 and this should take b5 they
just lead to two completely different
positions I think okay Bishop to b5 it's
just more comfortable for me it's very
clear a six and then kick the bishop and
then to attack along the C file d5 is a
lot more concrete I don't see anything
yet that I'm missing I guess if I was
missing something I wouldn't see him
anyway so that made no sense Cass KJ I
still don't know how to pronounce your
name cask J cask edge whatever your name
is thanks for the bits
that's very good sign he's thinking here
that means that like when he played b5
maybe he wasn't entirely clear what the
follow-up is okay d5 so do I need to
calculate more let's just go for this
yeah so maybe I can consider a night at
Fight Night or tonight c5 it's kind of
expecting this anyway one thing I forgot
to mention is that after it take and
then he takes on g6 I have rook e8 which
is good and yeah so if he if I take on
e6 Bishop take g6 rook g8 rook take e6 I
have 90 fades defending and attacking
everything so let's just take here so I
don't think he can take the Jeep on I
think that just loses a piece and he has
a choice between which pawns to take
always nice to give the point in a
choice when they're running low on time
and I think night c-5 will come no
matter what unless he does something
really unexpected odd fate 3000 or is it
odd vite I think it's odd veidt's right
thanks for the sub I'd see five so now
we both have week pawns I mean these
pawns are weak this pawn is weak he has
two bishops but I have more centralized
pieces and I'm ready to play rogue a
phase so this was essentially the line I
was calculating before and just assumed
York f8 has some nice pressure buildup
it's nice because most of his pawns are
unde arc squares all of his pawns are
isolated which makes it even better and
that for pawn especially is gonna be
hard to defend I wouldn't be surprised
if he tries to play one of these moves
and trades off bishop for a night and
then get some ox of Clare Bishop ending
which could very well happen it could be
Josh but I feel like there's still room
to play for a win okay so I can't take
on that for right away
guru calf 8 looks logical
and the whole premise is that if he goes
for this line I'm assuming that at some
point f2 is gonna be a major problem for
him because I'll have either rooked a
guy for or rook t2 and hopefully that's
enough to lead to a decisive advantage
I'm officially out of tea unfortunately
blazing hearts
thanks for the bits and good to see you
back
I don't know what he's gonna do here so
I feel like the rest of the moves at
least short-term are gonna be easy to
play for black maybe there's some chance
he could maybe generate some tactics
like there's an interesting line rook a
d1 rook take f4 rook take d6 rooked 86
Bishop takes e5 gets to bishops for a
rook but then I have rook t5 and maybe I
win something right back
because at Bishop III I've worked g4
check kind of looks risky though but I
don't see anything wrong with it
rook take f4
there's a rule if you don't see anything
wrong with it go for it and if you miss
something you learn something sometimes
it's a scary rule to follow I'm
searching for something wrong with rook
tiga for rotate d6 rotate d6 bishop
takes e5 rook g5 everything looks okay I
mean maybe there's a quiet move but if
he plays the quiet movie six will come
let's do it
just play the move hold my breath hope
for the best
except I'm not holding my breath because
I like to breathe
but I like the situation because it's
all up to a white like fine counter to
play it's all up to me just to play
normal moves and win material and very
soon I'll start having attacking
resources defending resources he could
still go to this opposite colored bishop
position we could trade like everything
he wins he's sick so I went f2 and I
still like my chances their time is
running low
King h1 unexpected I guess he's just
getting ready for a g4 Chuck oh and and
I guess he's threatening this this line
now because after up t5 fish at e3 would
actually be effective so I should
probably play b6 b6 kind of weakens the
light squares defends a bite King c7
also a possibility king c7 could run
into rotate d6
so let's play b6
and there's probably a move I can
consider coming up which is this move
rook h4 don't know if it would work
right away also why didn't I consider
ripped a keV - I guess I was scared of
rook take d6
just probably a reasonable thing to be
scared about but now I'm probably
threatening roe take F - and this can
get on each one is safer but it leaves
upon undefended whoa
I was unexpected my knight can just
capture and then oh it gets really weird
actually this interesting move because
if I take he can take on d6 with the
bishop I mean he's threatening my rook
he's also threatening edition of a6
check which is pretty uncomfortable so I
might have to like give back the
exchange and then grind down rook and
Knight versus rook and Bishop so if I
take he takes thinking about just taking
and then playing Knight c7 not too many
other options oh wait a minute the thing
is pin so I just have king b7 the king
b7 could be a simple move here and I
don't have to even worry about Bishop a6
I'm gonna play quicker because I think
things are under control and he's a long
time I'm just up exchange I appointed my
opponent just said something which gives
me a lot of confidence I might be losing
at the end I don't know what line he's
referring to it might be this line
because we're approaching the end Oh
didn't see it was pinned ah wow so this
is a variant yeah I missed the I
initially missed that into but it's kind
of the nature of time trouble it's easy
to miss simple things with low time so
that was an interesting game the Fort
Knox is one of these variations I think
it's simple to play a lot of people as
whites will play either 93 or 92 and if
you're lazy and you don't want to learn
theory in those lines just Bishop d7
Bishop c6 and it's playable I want to
explain just one thing just one
interesting new months is that
especially with this chap early on
disabled stockfish for a moment first of
all the the main trap here like a lot of
players might think Bishop g5 chops a
queen out of curiosity let's see how
many people walked into this on me chess
152 people yeah Bishop g5 is just a
blunder because after a bishop say got
three black wins a piece and it's so
nice it's not a strap because when white
plays Bishop g5 he's expecting to win
the Queen because the Queen has no
squares to move to there's an
interesting nuance if we go back to this
position because black would maybe like
to play the same chop right away with
Knight f6 and I take f6 Queen take f6
Bishop g5 but this line is actually good
for whites and this is
I think your white is winning material
because the difference being the b7 pawn
hangs and the rook and ends up being
traps but wait there's Queen d5 what's
going on here it's still playable Queen
d5 Queen CA kingi 7 Queen Dixie 7
Oh Queen d5 there's Bishop efore and
this is bad for black so that's the
whole reason of playing Knights Knight
be a to d7 first to make sure the rook
isn't getting trapped in those lines
where the Queen comes to f3 and then
okay then this was pleasant this
happened in masters games a few games
Bishop e2 there should be 2 makes a lot
of sense defending the pawn and making
sure there's no double pawns also night
g3 is a move I think Knight g3 is most
logical just to keep pieces on the board
because when it has more space so
interesting game thanks for playing
we'll have to have some kind of rematch
in drafts at some points so probably
what I'll do for this stream is cut up
whatever singular games I play and then
put them on youtube so probably just
this one game with analysis will be its
own YouTube video I've been doing this
recently but for the people watching
this in the future on YouTube thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the future